Scott asks what's your number one piece
of advice for marketing a lean local
city based social startup when we ask
for more details who responded that the
product isn't fully developed however
its social marketing for my city only
Scotty listen I took this question
because you tweeted that you wouldn't
eat until I answered your question and
knowing that eating is important I
wanted to deliver for you but I've got
to be honest with you and I love your
brother and your walk you know who I am
you're watching the show so you asked
the question I hate your question it's a
ludicrous thing to think about at this
point because the products not even
developed yet you're worried about
marketing I'd love for you to develop
the product taste it a little bit kind
of back to question number two or three
where you know it's you know you've got
to feel it you've got to put it out in
the wild reverse-engineer it a little
bit you know your you know my city only
like local there's a ton of things you
can do Facebook tower posts tweets
geolocation stuff there's a ton of
things to do mobile ads stuff there's
just an enormous amount of flexibility
on how to drill it with a local business
but the truth is you're getting ahead of
yourself
this is you know I don't wanna dis
number something to go and I don't want
to disk because I love you
it's a little bit of an amateurish
question I need you to kind of get the
app out or the product out you're just
getting way too ahead of yourself the
marketing will matter only if the
product is serviceable at some level I
mean great products always need less
great marketing and great marketing
doesn't fix crap products
you